Speaker 1: We are really now for the first
time seeing the rapid decline of coronavirus
cases.
In some states, it's down to almost a statistical
zero.
It's not literally zero cases, but it's statistically
low enough where there's really no spread.
Most people who are getting sick are not passing
it to anyone, and that's how you reduce the
number of cases.
This is just a good thing.
Let's look at the latest numbers, starting
with U.S. cases nationally, which have declined
now more than 93 percent from their peak.
The peak was 250, 5000 cases per day in late
January, now down early January, now down
below 18000 cases per day.
We are really getting there.
The deaths are fortunately starting to come
down with them.
Deaths are now down about 87 percent from
their peak below 500 a day from the year for
the first time since March of twenty.
Twenty deaths are at their lowest in about
15 months.
Now, is there anywhere in the US where cases
are going up?
Not really.
There are places where they sort of aren't
going down anymore and they tend to be places
with low rates of vaccination.
So Mississippi is an example where cases have
been level for about ten weeks.
They're not growing, but they're not really
shrinking anymore.
That's not great.
They need to vaccinate.
But lots of people there don't want the vaccine.
It's likely that eventually the places with
lower vaccination rates are going to just
see continued clusters while the highly vaccinated
states are going to go down to, again, statistically
zero, not literally zero, but almost in terms
of globally in South America, things are not
good.
And I was just looking at what's going on
in my birth country of Argentina.
And it's a disaster.
But overall, it's not just American cases
and deaths that are coming down.
Global cases are now declining pretty rapidly
from their peak at one point globally at eight
hundred and thirty thousand new global cases
per day.
That's now down about 40 percent to four hundred
eighty five thousand cases per day, down almost
half.
And then global deaths are also more slowly
declining, but down about twenty five percent
from their peak.
At one point 14000 humans per day were dying
from covid.
We still have about 11000 dying per day of
this virus.
Overwhelmingly, it's happening in the least
vaccinated countries.
Re restating, underlining the importance of
getting vaccines to all parts of the world.
This is not over, but in some places it will
effectively be over soon.
More mask mandates are being pulled in.
States were pulled over Memorial Day weekend.
The vaccines work well against the variants,
so it's not time to go crazy and do stupid
stuff.
I think at this point we all know what is
what is considered stupid at this point in
time.
Large gatherings of unvaccinated people indoors
is basically the stupidest thing you can do.
But vaccinated people can do most things with
what we would call baseline risk.
And this is a really important concept to
understand, because psychologically the pandemic
has really shaken up our concept of the risks
we accept by existing in the world.
Risk wasn't zero before this pandemic.
You could go out and you could get a cold,
you could go out and you could get the flu.
And sometimes people die of the flu.
You could go out and pick up a stomach bug
through physical contact or in a restaurant
or whatever you could get in a car accident.
So the question for me is not when is the
risk of covid zero, but it's when is it low
enough that we would consider when I go out,
I'm at baseline risk, meaning I'm accepting
that generally there's some risk to being
in the world, but there's not this acute thing.
And vaccines are a huge part of getting back
to that baseline level of risk, of just being
alive and existing in the world, even staying
home.
You could fall down the stairs.
I get it.
Even staying staying home.
You could poison yourself with lead paint.
I don't know.
But but the point here is there are lots of
people who before this pandemic were accepting
risks by being out in the world that maybe
they didn't even quantify.
And I think that now, because we're so aware
of it, it's going to feel scarier.
And like I get it, I was, you know, the other
day the grocery store there just before more
mass guidelines were pulled, the.
They were already a bunch of people without
masks, I was wearing my mask because that
was the rules at the time and I see the people
without the mask and it's like, whoa, whoa.
It's like you visualize a stream of germs
coming out of their mouth.
We accepted that before, right?
For my 30 whatever years that I lived until
the pandemic.
I accepted that and didn't think twice about
it.
The question is, when will we be back to that?
And then is that an acceptable level of risk
for some people?
Going back to the old level of risk, for example,
of flu won't be acceptable and people are
going to continue wearing a mask, and that's
fine, but it's going back to normal.
But it's sort of a new normal where I think
all of us are more aware of the risk to just
being out in the world now.
One last thing.
Vaccination keeps slowing down.
In the US, even though there are tons more
people to vaccinate, daily vaccine doses are
down to one point five million a day.
At one point, they were more than double that
three point three million a day.
There are tons of people still to vaccinate.
If they don't get vaccinated, some are going
to get covered and some are going to die.
And many doctors believe that because this
is going to keep circulating if you're not
vaccinated, that it's almost certain at some
point you will get it something to think about.
And that.
Let's now talk a little more about the psychological
impact of this pandemic